Welcome to the deep dive. I want you to picture something for a second. Whenever we hear about humans and artificial intelligence working together, it's, you know, it's usually pitched to us as this sort of technological superhero suit.
Right. Yeah. Like Iron Man.
Exactly. You step into it. The AI augments your natural abilities and suddenly you're, I don't know, stronger, faster and making just flawless decisions at work.
It's pretty much the ultimate promise of the modern tech industry, isn't it? The whole idea that one plus one equals three, like the human provides the intuition and the real world context while the AI brings. you know, the raw processing power and
the massive pattern recognition.
Yeah, that exact premise. But and this is what we're looking at today. What if you put on that multimillion dollar suit and instead of flying off into the sunset, you just immediately trip over your own feet? What if the hard data actually tells us that adding AI to a human workflow makes
us worse at our jobs? Because that is the mission of today's deep dive. We are looking at a stack of incredibly revealing research to figure out if human AI synergy is actually real, or if it's just this like persistent myth that we've all completely bought
into.
And we do have several crucial studies on the table today to help unpack that for you. But the absolute centerpiece of our discussion, like the main lens we'll be looking through, is a brand new, truly fascinating paper. It was published on September 21, 2026 in the
journal PNAS by Julian Berger and his colleagues at the Max Planck Institute for Human Development.
OK, let's unpack this, because before we can really appreciate the massive breakthrough in this 2026 Berger paper, We have to establish the rather depressing baseline that the scientific community had, you know, basically just accepted as a fact of life.
Yeah, we really need to talk about the AI penalty. To set the stage, we have to look back at a major 2024 meta-analysis. This was published in Nature Human Behavior by Vaccaro, Almatuk, and Malone. They wanted to survey the entire landscape of human-AI collaboration.
So they analyzed 74 different studies. I mean, we are talking about 370 distinct effect sizes. Wow. Which basically means 370 specific test scenarios across all sorts of tasks, everything from predicting house
prices to screening baggage at the airport to classifying medical images.
That is a massive, incredibly diverse data set. So when they zoomed out and looked at all these people working alongside AI, what was the bottom line? Like, did the suit work?
The headline was pretty bleak, honestly. On average, human-AI combinations did worse than the better of the human or the AI acting entirely alone.
Wait, worse?
Yeah, worse. In statistical terms, they found a Hedges G of about negative 0.23.
OK, let me stop you there for a second, just so we don't lose anyone in the math. Hedges G is essentially a way of standardizing performance differences across totally different types of experiments, right? So you can actually compare apples to oranges, like baggage screening versus medical scans.
Exactly. It gives us a standardized effect size, so everything is on the same scale. And a negative 0.23 is significant. So the prevailing narrative in the scientific community just became humans plus AI underperform.
That's wild.
Now, Vaccaro and colleagues did find some nuances. Like, there were performance losses on decision-making tasks, but some gains on creative, generative tasks. But the real shocker to many researchers was that giving the AI the ability to express its
confidence level, or providing the human with an explanation of how the AI reached its conclusion, it didn't actually help overall.
Wait, negative 0.23? So it's not just that the AI isn't helping, it's that the combination is actively dragging down the top performer. Yes. It's like pairing a Michelin star master chef with a high-tech recipe bot. You'd think they would create culinary
magic, but somehow the final dish tastes worse than if the chef just cooked from memory or the robot just, you know, followed its programming alone.
That is a brilliant way to visualize it. And you're right, the fact that explanations didn't help was a massive blow to the industry.
Which is wild to me because we're constantly told that explainable AI is the holy grail. Like if the machine can just tell you why it thinks a patient has a disease or why a loan should be denied, surely the human can make a better call.
Right, that's the intuition. But
the data said no. So, I mean, are we just inherently bad at collaborating with machines? Are human brains just too stubborn or too easily confused by algorithms?
Well, what's fascinating here is... It might not be a human flaw at all. It might just be bad science.
Wait, really? Bad science?
Yeah, a brand new analysis suggests researchers have been operating with this massive blind spot. And this is where Julian Berger's team comes in. They looked at that depressing 2024 meta-analysis of all 74 studies and asked a brilliant foundational question.
Which was?
Did any of these experiments actually give humans the chance to learn how to use the AI?
Okay, color me intrigued. How do you even measure whether someone had the chance to learn?
Well, they went back and recoded every single one of those 74 studies to look for one missing variable, which is human learning. And they found some shocking flaws in how these lab environments were set up.
Like what?
The typical study they reviewed was just a single session. Participants were given a median of only 30 trials.
That's nothing.
It's nothing. There were zero practice trials to get used to the AI's quirks. But, and here is the most damning part, out of the 74 studies, only 10 ever actually told the participants what the right answer was after they made a decision.
Wait, seriously.
Seriously.
Those scientists were testing how well humans use AI. But keeping the humans completely in the dark about whether the AI was actually right or wrong.
Yes. Out of 370 distinct effect sizes, only 98 featured any outcome feedback at all.
That is crazy.
And none of them varied the feedback experimentally. Put yourself in the shoes of a participant for a second. You're staring at a screen. You're asked to classify a lung scan. The AI pops up and says, I think it's a humor. You click agree or disagree. And then the screen just flashes to the next
scan. You never find out if it actually was a tumor. You never find out if the A.I. just gave you brilliant advice or terrible advice.
How on earth is someone supposed to build an accurate mental model of an A.I. teammate if they never know when it's lying to them? I mean, if you don't know the outcome, you are just clicking buttons in a vacuum.
Exactly. You can't build that mental model. And this isn't an isolated critique either. We can look at a parallel critique from a 2025 paper by Holman, Cale and Hartline to see how widespread this is.
OK, what did they find?
they analyzed a completely different set of AI assisted decision experiments. And they found that out of 39 studies, only 10 gave participants enough information to even identify the correct answer.
Wow. So these two critiques combined are basically saying the entire scientific field might be drawing these sweeping conclusions about human bias and human failure from like the absolute worst possible corner of the experimental design space. Precisely.
I mean, if you put someone in a vacuum, you don't let them practice and you actively hide from them when they make a mistake. Of course, they're going to underperform.
Right. So if the entire field was basically testing human AI teams in the dark. What happens when someone finally turns on the lights? Berger didn't just point out the flaw, right? They ran the numbers on what happens when you actually fix it.
They did.
But wait, I have to ask. Just telling someone good job or bad job at the end of a task, that can't possibly be enough to reverse the entire AI penalty, can it? What do the actual numbers look like?
Well, the numbers are fascinating. Berger's team used what are called robust Bayesian meta-regressions, which is really just a highly rigorous statistical method to analyze the data. Now, we do need to be intellectually honest with you here because the
sample size of studies that actually included feedback is so small, these results are tentative.
Okay, fair enough. But they
are incredibly compelling.
Here's where it gets really interesting. Let's hear the breakdown.
When humans were given no feedback, the human AI synergy trended negative, a Hedges G of about negative 0.17. Okay,
that matches the gloomy baseline.
Right. But when participants did receive outcome feedback, the synergy shifted. It trended positive to about 0.12.
Oh, wow. So we aren't just moving from failing to neutral. We are moving from actively sabotaging the AI to actually achieving that one plus one equals three promise we talked about in the intro.
Exactly. That is a contrast about 0.34. And their statistical models show an 84 percent probability of that shift being in a positive direction.
That's a huge swing.
It is. But the sharpest, most crucial finding, what I would call the real aha moment of this deep dive, has to be with those AI explanations we mentioned earlier.
Right. The explainable AI that Vaccaro's massive meta-analysis said was essentially useless.
Right. Well, Berger found that giving a human an AI explanation without any outcome feedback is actually actively harmful.
Harmful.
Yes. The synergy plummets to a negative 0.31 with a Bayes factor of 17.
Whoa, hang on. A Bayes factor of 17. Let's translate that from Satspeak for a second.
Sure. In plain English, a Bayes factor of 17 basically means the evidence for this finding is overwhelmingly strong. It's not a statistical fluke. Explanations without feedback cause real damage.
Okay, but what if they do have feedback?
If you give the human an AI explanation and you pair it with outcome feedback, the synergy skyrockets. It tends positive to about 0.3. That is a massive contrast of about 0.6 compared to the no feedback condition.
OK, let me make sure I'm wrapping my head around this. An AI explanation without feedback is basically like a highly charismatic, fast talking car salesperson. I like that. Right. Like they can talk you into buying an absolute lemon of a car because their logic sounds so flawless and
confident in the moment. And because you never get to see the car facts to check if they're telling the truth, you just blindly trust their convincing story.
That is a perfect analogy. Explanations make the AI persuasive, but persuasion has nothing to do with accuracy. The explanation only helps if you have the feedback loop, the Carfax, as you said, to learn how to verify the AI's work over time. And Berger's team actually
proved this within the studies, too. Oh,
they did? How?
They looked deeply into three specific experiments, what they called trial-level data sets, and watched it happen in real time. People actually learned to lean on a better performing A.I. over time, file by trial, but only when those informative feedback signals were
present.
That feels like a massive victory for human potential. I mean, we aren't broken. We just need the right environment to learn.
Yeah, exactly.
But and I'm guessing here I have a feeling the story doesn't wrap up neatly with a bow right here. Does feedback perfectly fix this charismatic AI problem every time?
No, it doesn't. And this raises a critical tension in the literature. It brings us to a 2021 study by Bansal and colleagues called Does the Hole Exceed Its Parts? Now, this study is actually one of the rare 10 studies from the meta analysis that did provide feedback.
OK, so they had the magic combo explanation plus feedback. What happened?
Banzal's team tested AI explanations on tasks like sentiment analysis, you know, judging if a book review is positive or negative, and answering tough logic questions from the LSAT.
Oh, LSAT questions. Okay.
Right. And even with feedback available, they found that giving humans AI explanations mostly just made people blindly accept the AI's advice. It increased their reliance on the AI regardless of whether the AI was actually right or wrong.
Wait, why do we do this? Even when we are being shown that the AI gets things wrong sometimes, why do our brains just default to trusting a well-written paragraph?
It comes down to a psychological phenomenon, often called automation bias, combined with cognitive offloading.
Cognitive offloading.
Yeah. When a machine gives us a highly detailed, logical-sounding paragraph... our brains take a cognitive shortcut. We subconsciously decide, well, the computer did the heavy lifting, it sounds authoritative, so I don't need to burn precious mental calories double checking its logic.
Which completely changes how we should look at human training. I mean, if humans are this easily manipulated by a well-written AI explanation, even when they do get feedback, should we even be trying to teach humans to calibrate their trust? It sounds like we
are just hardwired to fall for a confident answer.
That is the exact debate happening in the field right now. Is it a training problem or a design problem? Interestingly, Berger and his colleagues published a second paper in 2026 offering a totally different solution to this.
Oh, really?
Yeah. They argued that if training humans to calibrate their trust is too difficult, maybe we need to change the workflow itself.
Okay. How do we change the workflow to protect us from our own lazy brains?
It's called the hybrid confirmation tree, or HCT. Think about how almost all the studies we've talked about are set up. The AI acts as an advisor. You look at a problem. The AI withsters its advice in your ear along with its reasoning, and then you make the final call.
Right, the standard setup.
The HCT throws that entire model out the window.
So no whispering in the ear. How does a decision get made?
In the HCT model, the human, the AI, judge the problem completely independently. You don't see the AI's answer, and the AI doesn't see yours.
Oh, interesting.
If you both agree, that's the final decision. If you disagree, the problem gets kicked to a second human to break the tie.
That is fascinating. It completely removes the psychological influence of the charismatic AI. Like, you can't be persuaded by a fast-talking salesperson if you never actually meet the salesperson.
Exactly. And the results were stunning. The HCT model beat the traditional AI of a visor setup on all 10 datasets they tested it on.
All 10.
All 10. From detecting skin cancer to predicting recidivism to spotting deep fakes, it outperformed across all levels of human expertise. Wow. Why? Because the data shows that humans simply struggle to tell correct from incorrect AI advice when they are exposed to it
directly.
So what does this all mean? We have a real tension here. Is the future of AI synergy about building better interfaces to train humans to be better lie detectors using feedback loops like the PNAS paper suggests? Or is the future about
designing defensive workflows like the HCT where humans never even see the AI's advice in the first place because we frankly just can't handle it?
it is likely going to depend heavily on the environment you are operating in. And that brings us to the real-world caveats of Berger's PNAS paper. We need to remember that their meta regression was correlational. It was between study and it was ultimately based on only 24
effect sizes that actually featured both AI explanations and feedback.
Right. A relatively small slice of the pie.
Very small. But the biggest caveat comes down to a concept by the psychologist Robin Hogarth. It's the difference between kind and wicked learning environments.
OK, I love this concept. Walk me through what makes a learning environment kind or wicked.
A kind learning environment is one where feedback is accurate, it is timely, and the features you need to pay attention to are obvious. In these environments, you can learn very quickly. Okay. A wicked learning environment is one where feedback is noisy, it's delayed by months or
years, or the connection between your decision and the outcome is incredibly murky. Feedback only creates human AI synergy if the environment is kind enough to let you learn from it in the first place.
So a kind environment is like playing a video game. You're running through a level. You jump too late. You fall into a pit and lose a life instantly. Boom. Perfect, clean, immediate feedback. You adjust your timing on the next try. Exactly. But a wicked environment
is like corporate strategy or hiring. You might use an AI to help you filter resumes and hire a marketing director. But you might not know if the AI gave you bad advice for five years until that director runs a campaign that bankrupts the company.
Precisely. Or take medicine. If you're a doctor getting AI advice on an x-ray, do you actually find out the biopsy results the next day, or does that patient disappear into the broader healthcare system, leaving you with zero feedback on whether the AI was right?
Oh, that's dark, but so true.
So the question for you listening to this right now is, does your real-world workplace actually give you the clean trial-by-trial feedback that a laboratory can? If your workplace is a wicked environment, providing you with AI explanations
might just be making you dangerously overconfident.
That is a terrifying but necessary reality check. We have to synthesize what this means for all the organizations, the managers, and especially the educators out there who are rushing to deploy AI tools. You cannot just hand your team or your students an AI
assistant, turn it on, and expect magic synergy.
No, you absolutely cannot. If we connect this to the bigger picture, human learning is the ultimate understudied lever in the AI revolution. We spend billions of dollars training the models and almost zero time training the humans how to interact with them.
So if you are leading a team, you have to deliberately build in feedback loops. You have to offer practice trials where the stakes are zero so people can learn the AI's quirks without crashing the company. And at a higher level, you have to explicitly ask yourself, are we
training our people to rigorously verify the AI or are we just quietly training them to accept whatever it says because it spits out a convincing paragraph?
Technology is only as good as our ability to adapt to it. The AI penalty we discussed at the start isn't necessarily a failure of the machine. It is a failure of our learning environment.
I want to leave you with a final thought to mull over, something that really builds on this idea of learning environments. The research we looked at today assumes a static AI. It assumes an AI that behaves the exact same way in trial one as it does in trial
100.
Right, which isn't how modern AI works.
No, because today's generative AI models, the ones we are all using right now on our phones and laptops, they are designed to constantly learn and adapt from our prompts in real time.
They are moving targets. They change their behavior based on how you interact with them.
Exactly. So if AI is learning and changing its behavior constantly based on you, how can a human ever establish a stable feedback loop to calibrate their trust? If the superhero suit of armor is constantly changing its shape, its weight, and its controls while you are wearing it, you are
never going to learn how to fly. In the modern race for human-AI synergy, you really have to ask yourself, who is actually training whom?